He starts by saying "Alif Lam Mim."
Does mankind think that it will be
enough for him to be a Muslim and not be
tested? Do you think that Allah Subhana
Wa Ta'ala will leave you just because
you're Muslim and Allah Subhana Wa
Ta'ala will not test that?
Allah Subhana Wa Ta'ala goes on to
mention "Wa la ya'laman Allah alladheena
sadaqoo." Allah Subhana Wa Ta'ala he
said that we tested the people who came
before you.
So that we can distinguish and determine
who is truthful in their Iman.
Who is truthful in their statement that
they are believer.
"Wa la ya'laman al kadhibeen." To
distinguish those who are faithful and
true in their belief and their Iman from
those who are just lying and pretending.
So my dear brothers, when you claim that
you are Muslim, when you say to people,
WHEN PEOPLE COME AND ADVISE YOU because
you're doing haram and they say to you
"Itaqillah." AND YOU SAY "DON'T JUDGE
ME. Only Allah can judge me." Remember,
Allah Subhana Wa Ta'ala will test your
Iman. Allah Subhana Wa Ta'ala will test
your faith and see if you're truthful in
YOUR ISLAM. JUST BECAUSE YES, Allah
Subhana Wa Ta'ala is the one who judges
and Allah Subhana Wa Ta'ala is the one
who holds us to accountable on the day
of judgement, that doesn't give you a
free pass to do whatever you want and
think that as long as the people cannot
come and approach me, I that that I can
do whatever I want. Allah Subhana Wa
Ta'ala he will test your Iman.
Allah Subhana Wa Ta'ala he said
qareeb. Allah Subhana Wa Ta'ala he
mentioned "Do you think that you will
enter paradise?" THE THING THAT EACH AND
EVERY ONE OF US DESIRE, TO GO TO JANNAH.
ALLAH SAYS DO YOU THINK THAT you will be
ABLE TO GO TO PARADISE?
"WA LAMMA YA'TIKUM MATHALU ALLADHEENA
KHALAW MIN QABLIKUM." AND IT WILL NOT
COME TO YOU THE TRIALS AND TRIBULATIONS
THAT CAME THAT SIMILAR THAT CAME TO THE
PEOPLE WHO WERE BEFORE YOU.
VARIOUS DIFFICULT DIFFERENT DIFFICULTIES
AND TRIALS AND TRIBULATIONS came their
way.
"WA ZULZILU HATTA" AND THEY WERE SHAKEN.
"HATTA YAQOOL AR RASOOLU WALLADHEENA
aamanoo ma'ahoo mata nasrullah." THEY
WERE TESTED SO SEVERELY
TO THE EXTENT THAT THE MESSENGER AND
THOSE who believed with him
THEY WOULD SAY "MATA NASRULLAH." WHEN IS
THE AID AND VICTORY OF ALLAH GOING TO
COME? And Allah said "Ala inna
nasrullahi qareeb." Surely it is Allah's
victory which is going to be near. So my
dear brothers, when you're GOING THROUGH
A TRIAL AND YOU'RE GOING THROUGH A
DIFFICULTY, DO NOT COMPROMISE YOUR
RELIGION.
THAT TRIAL AND TRIBULATION SHOULD BE A
MEANS for you TO DRAW NEARER TO ALLAH
SUBHANA WA TA'ALA. THE BELIEVER, WHEN HE
GOES THROUGH A DIFFICULT TIME OR HE IS
TESTED IN HIS DUNYA, WHETHER IT BE IN
HIS RISK OR HIS CHILDREN OR HIS FAMILY,
THE FIRST THING THAT HE DOES, THE FIRST
CHARACTERISTIC
IS HE HASIBU ANFUSAKUM QABLA AN TUHASIB.
JUST LIKE THE UMAR IBN AL-KHATTAB HE
MENTIONED TO THE PEOPLE, HE SAID BRING
YOURSELF TO ACCOUNT BEFORE YOU'RE
BROUGHT TO ACCOUNT.
So the believer, WHEN HE GOES THROUGH A
DIFFICULTY, THE FIRST THING THAT HE
DOES,
HE LOOKS AT HIMSELF. HE DOESN'T LOOK AT
THE OTHER PEOPLE.
HE DOESN'T LOOK AT THE PERSON DOING THE
THING TO HIM. HE ASKS HIMSELF, PERHAPS
IT'S SOMETHING THAT I HAVE DONE. PERHAPS
IT IS SOME SORT OF GOOD DEED THAT I HAVE
FALLEN SHORT IN.
PERHAPS IT'S SOME OF THE WAJIBATS OF
ALLAH THAT I HAVE BECOME LAX AND
LACKADAISICAL WITH.
PERHAPS IT IS ME STARTING TO INDULGE
INTO IN SOME HARAM THAT I MAY ONCE NEVER
HAVE INDULGED IN.
THIS IS THE WAY AND THIS IS THE
MENTALITY OF THE BELIEVER. AND HE
CORRECTS THOSE THINGS FIRST BEFORE HE
GOES AND CORRECTS THINGS outside of
that. So the next time you GO THROUGH A
DIFFICULTY, MY BROTHERS, ASK YOURSELF
AND BE HONEST WITH YOURSELF. HOLD
YOURSELF ACCOUNTABLE. WHAT IS IT THAT I
AM DOING THAT MAY BE THE REASON WHY I'M
GOING THROUGH THIS DIFFICULT TIME. The
salaf THEY USED TO SAY
THE WAY TO DISTINGUISH BETWEEN WHETHER
ALLAH SUBHANA WA TA'ALA IS TESTING YOU
OR WHETHER ALLAH SUBHANA WA TA'ALA IS
PUNISHING YOU. THE SALAF THEY USED TO
SAY
THAT IF THAT TRIAL BRINGS YOU CLOSER TO
ALLAH, THEN IT'S VERY LIKELY THAT THAT
WAS A TEST from Allah Subhana Wa Ta'ala.
And if that TRIAL AND THAT DIFFICULTY
PUSHES YOU FURTHER AWAY FROM THE DEEN,
THEN IT'S MOST LIKELY THAT that is a
punishment. SO MY DEAR BROTHERS, BRING
YOURSELF TO ACCOUNT BEFORE YOU'RE
BROUGHT to account.
BECAUSE THIS IS THE OPPORTUNITY you have
to do it. ONCE YOU PASS ON TO THE NEXT
LIFE, THAT OPPORTUNITY TO BRING YOURSELF
ACCOUNT WILL WILL NO longer be there, my
brothers.
Allah Subhana Wa Ta'ala he said
REGARDING DIFFICULTIES AND TRIALS AND HE
ENCOURAGES US through the Quran and in
the Sunnah. Allah Subhana Wa Ta'ala he
said "Fa inna ma'a al-usri yusra. Inna
ma'a al-usri yusra." THAT INDEED WITH
EVERY HARDSHIP comes ease. Then Allah
REPEATED IT AGAIN AND SAID WITH EVERY
HARDSHIP comes ease. And for those who
are aware of the Arabic language, then
they know that Allah Subhana Wa Ta'ala
he uses a specific GRAMMATICAL RULE HERE
THAT EMPHASIZES
yaqeen and emphasizes CERTAINTY
AND TAWKEED THAT ALLAH SUBHANA WA TA'ALA
HE WILL make things easy after those
hardships. THEN ALLAH REPEATED IT AGAIN
AND SAID "Inna ma'a al-usri yusra."
My dear brothers, each and every single
person will be tested and trialed in
this dunya.
He
received the harshest and most severe
test are the Anbiya, the prophets.
Thumma as-salihun.
Then those who are righteous. Thumma
al-amthal fal-amthal. Then those who are
similar to them. So that test is going
to be in accordance to the level of your
Iman.
The closer you get to Allah Subhana Wa
Ta'ala, the more you draw nearer to him,
the more you pray your salawat, THE MORE
YOU ATTEND THE MASJID, then those tests
are going to be harder.
But that doesn't mean that Allah Subhana
Wa Ta'ala he will trial you and test you
with something that you cannot handle.
"La yukallifullahu nafsan illa wus'aha."
Allah Subhana Wa Ta'ala he will never
test you with something that you cannot
bear, something that you cannot handle.
When Allah Subhana Wa Ta'ala tests you,
he knows that you have the ability to
come out the other side a stronger
believer and someone who is closer to
him.
And Allah Subhana Wa Ta'ala also in an
authentic hadith mentioned by the
Prophet Muhammad Sallallahu Alaihi
Wasallam where he mentioned that if
Allah Subhana Wa Ta'ala he loves a
slave, he puts him through trials and
tribulations.
Because those trials and tribulations,
like I said at the beginning, it causes
the believer to draw nearer nearer to
Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala. You yuqarrib"
HE GETS CLOSER TO ALLAH SUBHANAHU wa
ta'ala not further.
When he's tested,
HE DOESN'T PULL OUT HIS HAIR and scream
and shout and say, "Why me? Why me?"
The believer when he's tested, he
remains patient. And the Prophet
Muhammad sallallahu alayhi wa sallam he
mentioned that in authentic hadith that
I I
He said that the affair or the situation
of the believer is strange and it's
amazing.
Why is the affair of the believer
amazing? The Prophet sallallahu alayhi
wa sallam continued to mention that
indeed all of
indeed all of the believer's affairs for
him is khair, is good FOR HIM.
WHEN
WHEN DIFFICULTIES WHEN DIFFICULTIES AND
TRIALS AND TRIBULATIONS COME HIS WAY,
FOR SOME OF THEM KHAIR
WHEN THE BELIEVER IS HIT WITH A TRIAL
AND TRIBULATION, what does he do? For
some of them He remains patient and
steadfast.
WHAT KIND OF KHAIR
AND IT IS BETTER for him. Why? BECAUSE
WHEN YOU REMAIN PATIENT DURING THE
DIFFICULT TIME
AND YOU PRAISE Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala
and you do not complain to the people.
INNA MA ASHKU BATHI WA HUZNI ila Allah
and you complain to Allah subhanahu wa
ta'ala regarding your problems and you
ask Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala to make it
easy for you. What do you receive, my
dear brothers? You receive reward from
Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala. SO THAT
DIFFICULTY IN ACTUALITY CAUSED YOU TO BE
REWARDED.
WHEN
AND IF SOMETHING FROM HAPPINESS OR JOY
COMES TO HIM, when Allah SUBHANAHU WA
TA'ALA BLESSES YOU WITH A CHILD ALLAH
SUBHANAHU WA TA'ALA HE BLESSES YOU WITH
ALLAH BLESSES YOU WITH WEALTH THAT IS
GOOD AND BENEFICIAL for you and good
health
and Allah gives you the things that you
weren't ASKING HIM FOR. WHAT DOES THE
BELIEVER DO?
The
believer he gives thanks to Allah
subhanahu wa ta'ala.
He goes and if Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala
blesses him with some money, he goes AND
GIVES SADAQA AND he helps more people.
If Allah SUBHANAHU WA TA'ALA BLESSES HIM
WITH A CHILD A healthy child, he goes
and and and and and does aqiqah for that
child and feeds people because Allah
subhanahu wa ta'ala blessed him.
So my dear brothers, IF THAT CHILD is
not drawing you closer to Allah
subhanahu wa ta'ala and that child in
difficulty is causing you to fall into a
depressed state and go further than
Allah go go further away from Allah,
then ask yourself and bring yourself to
account and be honest with yourself
because THERE'S NO POINT LYING TO
YOURSELF.
We can lie to the creation. We can fool
and deceive the people
and make it seem as if there's no hope,
but Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala he will
never test you with something that you
cannot handle. So my dear brothers,
remember that if you want Allah
subhanahu wa ta'ala to take out take you
out of difficult difficult situation
that you may be going through, remember
that the शर्त for this is that you
remain steadfast and you stick to the
duties of Islam. Allah subhanahu wa
ta'ala he says in the Quran that whoever
fears Allah
Whoever
Whoever fears Allah
fears Allah
Whoever fears Allah and keeps his duty
to Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala
Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala he gives him a
makhraj makhraj min ayyi diq Any
difficulty that he may be going through
Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala gives him a
way out and a solution.
Then Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala he goes
on to mention Whoever
fears Allah
And Allah provides FOR THAT PERSON FROM
places that he thought that Allah would
never provide.
Whoever fears Allah
AND WHOEVER PLACES HIS TRUST AND
RELIANCE UPON ALLAH WHOEVER
WHOEVER PLACES HIS RELIANCE ON
THE ONE WHO CREATED YOU FROM NOTHING
THOUGH IF YOU PLACE YOUR TRUST IN HIM,
FOR ALLAH
then Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala he
suffices that person. Allah suffices
that person from needing any individual
or any advice or any money or anything
that he may require, Allah becomes
sufficient for that person.
And if Allah subhanahu WA TA'ALA BECOMES
SUFFICIENT FOR THAT PERSON, that person
doesn't require anything else in this
life because he will find his answers
all there. Likewise Allah subhanahu wa
ta'ala he mentioned Whoever
fears Allah
Whoever fears Allah
Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala if you keep
your duty to him and fear him, Allah
subhanahu wa ta'ala he pardons that
person for their sins and their
wrongdoings and Allah subhanahu wa
ta'ala rewards them. Allah subhanahu wa
ta'ala Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala
Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala Allah
subhanahu wa ta'ala